movie opens with 17 seconds of bad CG
space porn if the predator has the
space-time opening thing about Bob on
his ship then why in the fuck did he
wait until now to use it could have
easily done this earlier before we
started taking hits from the other ship
aliens that crash-landed movie has
always seemed to find jungle areas that
just so happened to have army guys on a
mission
two morons really making bets on whether
a drug cartel is executed these hostages
check I'm in for 20 character poses a
question about the moral integrity of
his fellow cohorts and then goes along
with them proving he is even more
ethically challenged cliche this is also
known as the Shane black school of
character development I would have loved
to have heard the phone call setting up
this hostage meet you know that muddy
area in the middle of nowhere where
there's a random street light setup of
course who doesn't good when we think 10
don't wear nice shoes it's too bad that
we humans evolved to be attracted to the
green goo we cannot resist its
mysterious nature and desire to touch it
it's evidence ain't nobody gonna believe
this one but they will when Quinn shows
them a mask they're more likely to think
he's stopped by a party city so you're
telling me the predator skin to Haines
alive 30 feet from Quinn and Dupree and
they didn't hear a scream or whatever
the sound skinning a human makes what
did the predator show itself even that
long predator movie steals the weapon
arm thing from Daniel Craig and Cowboys
and Aliens and just like Craig he
doesn't know how this works but it will
conveniently ex machina situations
throughout the movie this is an
excellent shot but wouldn't the blood
just be pouring in the Predators eyes
unexplained ball from the arm weapon
that just knocked a predator unconscious
and sliced my buddy in half probably not
that dangerous
sterling K Brown comes in already
chewing a Nicorette pops another here
and goes for yet another one here
how much goddamn Nicorette do you need
and how much Nicorette explains that the
character might be battling something I
guess is one piece one piece but why do
that when you need to show the man Scott
diamond yo know what's in the package
not the backpack yeah why not just give
him the pack Goodin doesn't even know
how well this guy speaks English damn
dude you have no idea what's in this
thing sure you're worried about someone
stealing it why not just go ahead and
camouflage yourself and avoid the cops
avoiding potentially inserting
radioactive isotopes in your body
my guess is that this is a Shane Black
special here where the school
abbreviated students to STD s and we're
apparently not aware of their mistake
and while I'm laughing my ass off
welcoming us t DS into a middle school
is no laughing matter
use protection kids abstinent sucks but
it's 100% effective hmm
Jess critics kids the teacher in this
class just strolls out of the classroom
while his special needs student Rory
stands in the back easily seen and
obviously trouble
god damn it can we have one student who
isn't constantly bullied in these movies
Jesus to show his amazing mental
capacity the movie shows Rory putting
the chess pieces back on the boards
exactly as they were before the two fire
alarm pulling dickheads knocked all the
pieces to the floor and when he's done
it's quite a feat but it doesn't come
without some errors just one example the
give away is this board which shows from
left to right a queen a king and a
bishop in the background Wow the one
here shows from left to right a pawn a
queen and a king in the background no
one knows why a pawn would be there
can't be there really but hey nobody's
saying that isn't a great feat even with
the mistakes and being here before 87 97
they were also here in 2007 we don't
discuss that as badass it's pretty
morbid there's a pretty dog hi it made
no sense for me to be carrying around
apples all this time so instead I chew
gum so you'll recognize I'm the asshole
I don't know don't worry about him he's
just got two Reds you can control it
I'm sure this character will be treated
in a sensitive manner that won't have
him swearing up a storm for laughs every
time we see him cuz never mind
that's coil Friendly Fires that got
turned around if either one of us all
vehicles no joke
crazy people exposition nuts position is
it just your imagination or is this
haunted room actually stretching all the
stars has made me realize the Haunted
Mansion ride at Disney World is way more
fun than this movie and is over in less
than 10 minutes I'm Shaun Keyes bones
for the three people who loved predator
2 to applaud if the Predators have been
here before and these guys have
experience with them then everyone
should know those couple of straps
aren't gonna hold the damn thing down
when it wakes up party
well you know because we called it
something else it would be harder to get
people into movie theaters we called it
the predator and it was still hard to
get people into movie theaters
data suggests that it tracks its prey
exploit sweetness it's not a predator
that's a sports hunter dr. Brackett
would be amazing at cinema sales also a
movie tries very hard to come up with an
explanation as to why it's called the
predator even somewhat joking that it's
wrong but even with all that I still
can't believe a bunch of people decided
to call this thing predator based on
that when you have so many cooler
aspects to derive a name like its
dreadlocks or scary-ass tusks or the
nightmare mouth well we took a vote
predators cool it right they took a vote
everyone agrees it's cooler this
specimen has human DNA mostly plants and
insects but but some mammals sheep goats
dialogue was written this way I guess
just to make sure no one was left out
guys I get it you want to know if
someone's an alien yeah really feel like
not having the tagline for this movie
being you'll know if someone can alien
was a missed opportunity it's hilarious
to me when movies date something right
around the time the movie was released
like the first predator was released on
June 12th 1987 so obviously in this
world the events were taking place at
the same time I guess in a parallel
universe or something to think predator
was just fun escapism in our world but
in their world a deadly reality also
didn't the guy a few minutes ago say
they've been here before 87 97 yeah yeah
he did say 97 which is when predator 2
was set even though the movie came out
in 1990 also is jake Busey's character
who is named keys ever going to bring up
that his dad has experience with these
things is it just a fun casting callback
assuming this was the ship chasing the
human hybrid predator at the beginning
of the movie why did it take him so long
to get to earth the ship clearly has the
same abilities as the other ship to open
a space-time continuum
wait are these subtitles telling us
what's going on are they some sort of
futuristic floating text that predators
can read when they're searching for
mother I guess it could be about fuck
did we really need any of this to tell
us what's going on why would the ship
deke look at this very moment what's the
purpose you were just fine being
invisible cool shot and all but bodies
aren't the same as bulletproof vests at
least half of those would probably go
straight through her body and into his
and since we find out later that this
predator is actually here to help the
humans maybe he should have tried a
different approach once he woke up other
than brutally murdering everyone around
him okay so the predator can imitate
human voices fine but when did he ever
hear or see this dude talking into the
hand and voice burn ID thing remember
when Church Thomas J said his thing he
was way down in this corridor while the
predator was strapped to the table
fighting off human fodder also this is
nitpicky but there's a little something
lost in the storytelling when the
predator managed to also somehow get
church's hand during this process which
you barely see in the background of this
shop I had to rewind that five times to
find Church getting shot in the
background while olivia munn gets her
action shot in for the day so does he
let her live because she's attractive
and make it or naked and unarmed or just
on a mouse it's one of the most
confusing scenes in the movie casey
briefly mentions it in this scene when
they're running up some stairs but it's
never explored again if this asshole
could open the doors without Church
Thomas J then why did he even bother
with the hand and voice print ID a
minute ago Jenga
good news for the predator this mask was
taken out of its box and it's pointing
towards something useful so he can find
this kid later also are they saying that
the predator helmets connect to each
other where you can see what the other
helmet sees like if I were a predator I
could hack into Jim Joe Bob predator his
helmet and see what he sees that's an
invasion of privacy only Facebook good
luck Oh
unnecessary orders these army guard guys
are the stupidest people in history
everything they do here is likely not
what you do when you're trying to break
up a fight on a prison bus I'm no
predator weapon expert but that shot
looked really high to have hit the tire
also Olivia Munn is able to stay on top
of the bus after this get to the top if
this movie had been a little less
wink-wink nudge-nudge I don't know more
say good then maybe I'd give more about
this line and don't want to rip both my
ears off with bare hands everything okay
well predator brought whatever their
equivalent of bloodhounds are on this
trip and I say that because it's not
stupid at all guys I will say this scene
is awesome wish the rest of the movie
could have been on the same level as
this scene but this is worth at least
one Zimmerman you just said this goes on
for some time it's called the predator
yeah we've heard it a bunch but roll
credits the kid from room puts this mask
on for no reason whatsoever it shows him
a double YouTube video of a predator
getting injected with something why is
this mask showing anything right now
daytime trick-or-treating what is this a
halloween sequel so does rory have leave
whenever he wants to go
trick-or-treating rights in this house
and they also managed to walk out the
door with a giant predator mask on
without her seeing him no man I'm
wondering with this movie have been
successful if they had called it the
Whoopie holy like I bet Fox is kicking
themselves right now yes yeah Rory said
that the bullies would be able to figure
out if it's him no matter what mask he
wore but this is some great able that
they recognize him with this thing on to
be fair the guy had his porch light on
and wasn't answering the door so he 100%
deserved this well good thing they were
driving down this road for a perfect
view of an explosion just in case it
happened also goes up with this
neighborhood every single house has a
jack
sitting at the front of the driveway
it's like this movie stole footage from
Rob Zombie's Halloween to make this
thing that helmet just killed a bunch of
people in this house a second ago but at
least Rory taught the bullies a lesson
people dead because of him this is the
kid spooked he's grabbing it where is he
headed where someplace he knows of
course this means that absentee father
Quinn will make a direct beeline to find
his son on a baseball field because of
course he does
you know there been a lot of dumb
creature ideas in movies killer
leprechauns goalies and puppet masters
but predator dogs might be the absolute
worst I mean why did the dogs have
dreadlocks to to Nebraska just
lobotomize as a predator dog because it
sure looks like Nebraska just
lobotomized a predator dog and now
they're just letting it wander the
streets for some reason what the okay
yeah I mean I just straight up murdered
a dude a few minutes ago so I'll
probably have to deal with those
repercussions at some point but
otherwise can't complain I don't
understand this predator guy no problem
killing everything asshole that walks in
his path but when it comes to Quinn and
his merry band of crazy army dudes he
lets them live in every situation
predator vs. predator Requiem you know
what I think I think this one went rogue
a runner and I base that on absolutely
nothing I could possibly know at this
point in time holy for this whole movie
I thought this was Charlie Hunnam and
now I realize it's Boyd Holbrook from
Logan I bet these guys stirred up some
double trouble back when they were kids
in the same high school in Kentucky in
England Tuesday's game I never grew up
the way I won great skip this is more
than spine awful you know that by
looking at it under a microscope a
species you haven't even gotten a chance
to study yet don't we have to run some
tests to make this proclamation did you
not see the new predator it's evolving
you're not graded can we get through
this movie before we start working on
titles for the next one
how did Trager find Quinn and all the
military guys at their hideout we know
they were looking for Rory but what did
they use to track them down in the
middle of nowhere like this that's I've
always wanted a predator movie to turn
into a Beethoven sequel see prayers can
be answered driving a hothouse
environment maybe they want to move in
ours but why all the other predator
movies have set up that they simply
enjoy hunting different species and
killing them it's never been anything
said about them needing a new planet to
live on
this is some left-field bull to be
throwing at us with only 30 minutes left
it's as if this kid writes his name on
everything and places it conveniently in
case a predator comes by the house and
need some information quickly
predator dog ex machina Jesus he even
brought Achra nade this would be the
first dog aptly named lucky
Madame what's your 20 I can follow your
boys top-right lock into his frequency a
super secret government chopper can be
tracked by a news trapper I'm trying to
figure out with these birds chirping
mother listen sands and Satan said when
you were 11 somehow despite traitors
helicopter leaving way earlier than
Quinn's helicopter Gwen was still able
to get here in time to see his son enter
the alien spaceship from his sniper nest
this also means that Quinn's helicopter
landed somewhere without anyone hearing
it or detecting it he'd aborted and ran
to his position before Trager led Rory
here so cuz Krieger been waiting for
word this whole time and then a range of
sniper tripping and wise senses
he's gotta be creating witness
camouflage right now why did he need a
diversion why not go for the sneak
attack
not even clue anyone in the DS here all
the tripwire thing does is get everybody
on alert he in slice oh Jesus why though
does the predator even care about this
guy sure the movie needed a way to
complicate Quinn's escape plan but the
idea that the predator was just
wandering around in the woods and just
happened to run into Quinn's key sniper
it's a major this triggers still talking
smack to Quinn with an 11-foot predator
nearby because the movie says the
predator loves hunting as much as
killing he puts Quinn and the rest of
the crew in a most dangerous game
situation or because the Busey
connection is surviving the game
situation but truly honestly you gotta
be kidding me
also a movie takes an hour in 19 minutes
to truly predator
why would he throw the predator
boomerang still just firing his gun
after Brackett has to be the most
combat-ready biologist ever for
absolutely no reason at all Beck's goes
in for a close-up knife kill where the
predator is not only losing the fight
but is on fire not to mention the hail
of bullets going into his body right now
what's a knife gonna do I don't think
the predator weapon is supposed to work
that way
also funny death and all but you give
that to one of the henchmen not your
main looking human villain coiling
Baxley were going to die agonizing
deaths and they knew they had to kill
each other but damn I didn't even count
to three how did they know when to fire
I love
what does this do well see you really
think this distraction is going to be
enough to stop the predator and give his
kid a chance to get out of the jungle so
why hasn't he told Rory to get invisible
already why would the predator after
scanning everybody and finding one crew
warrior simply call the kid McKenna when
there are two McKenith this is like
office space when Drew tells Peter that
joannec lumber knowing full well that
Lumbergh is what everybody calls the
boss and not that asshole with the same
last name who moved to Atlanta in all
honesty this should be exactly like the
other guys when the rock and samuel
l.jackson jump off a building and just
die considering mr. Shane black I'd
almost expect him to think the same way
here but I guess he's not above heaping
loads of bull on the audience when the
movie needs a hero to save the day with
my son inside it yeah why does the force
shield start covering the ship like a
rolled-up blanket instead of simply
covering the entire ship on demand this
works even if he memorized the code his
kid put in the other ship it's the same
code and it opens during flight Quinn
gets pulled out of the ship with the
grading tied to his foot but grading of
course prevents him from falling out of
the ship immediately he somehow misses
every tree possible the grading finally
gives and allows Quinn to hang from a
tree and I might be out of Tolerance and
my book bank has gone broke why are you
no invisible did she find a little ball
that worried dropped in the middle of
the dark ass woods remember in the
original when Arnie had to use the
predator strength against it and set
traps well now we just have Boyd
Holbrook fight at mano-a-mano and still
somehow come out the victor that's so
much better
toss it Aaron Rogers taught her well
what are you God out of all the dumb
callbacks to the original this might be
the worst because Quinn already knows
exactly what the predator is also I'm
confused bullets never did to the
predator the entire time they were
firing billions of them earlier why do
they work now is it because he finally
has the advantage and it's time for the
movie to be over just now damn dude
you've cracked the predator code pretty
quickly in this movie you knew nobody
could know unless they had your magical
brain abilities and yet even after
figuring out everything you still had to
wait for the pod to send you a message
about what was inside a predator killer
technology gifted to the humans does
everything in its power to seem
malevolent when all it really had to do
was leave some goddamn instructions
that's my new suit Bubba I hope they got
into 42 long double side
whichever seat right there please as you
might have heard we recently announced
the inaugural year of sin week it's
coming up soon
polish sin week is an E convention that
you can access at all levels of patreon
it will have five cinemasins videos that
week for members panels a live podcast
and much more and if you're signed up at
the top tier you're eligible to attend
sin week in-person hang out with Chris
Jeremy and the sentence gang in
beautiful Nashville Tennessee you'll be
digging up golf
you'll even be treated to some great
food if you haven't already sign up
today at patreon.com slash cinemasins
join the club we space the final
frontier these are the voyages of the
Starship Enterprise yes you'd like to
see the big tomorrow huh one second it's
on the grid the next it's ghosting I got
some beers they strike him allow me to
introduce myself my name is cold I'm
kind of like the leader in here he
supervised 23 close precision
engagements across five continents and
he has 13 confirmed kills
and he is one of only 14 captains in the
Armed Forces to ever receive a
Distinguished Service Medal and a Silver
Star
I love chuck Bartowski and I don't know
what to do about it
this can only be one person for the
enemy i'ma rip your face off bitch
I immediately regret this decision
Casey I'll be right he needs some milk
what are you I'm Batman